digamos que esta serie donde el índice
comienza en 2 y nos seguimos recorriendo
la suma hasta infinito es de la
siguiente forma menos ocho quintos más
16 séptimos menos 32 novenos y así
seguimos sumando hasta el infinito
entonces lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es determinar explícitamente
quiénes son los genes los términos para
cada n que empieza en 2 y se sigue hasta
el infinito entonces te invito ahorita
en este momento a poner pausa para que
lo pienses lo intentes tú solo y veamos
si coincidimos con el mismo resultado
entonces para poder hacerlo lo que voy a
hacer es fijarme primero quiénes son
estos términos decimos el primer término
tendrá que ser a 2 porque empezamos con
2 verdad entonces a 2
menos ocho quintos muy bien a tres
a 3 será igual a 16 séptimos y a 4 a 4
será igual a menos 32 menos 32 novenos
muy bien entonces con esta información
vamos a tratar de determinar quiénes son
todos los n y para eso vamos a primero
detectar los patrones que hay en el
numerador entonces nos podemos fijar de
hecho de hecho podemos pasar este signo
menos al numerador verdad de este signo
menos el numerador y éste también eso
nos va a servir mucho para detectar
estos patrones entonces ya que tenemos
este hecho vamos a ver que para que
menos 8 para llegar a 16 hay que
multiplicar aquí por 2 y para cambiar el
signo por menos entonces hay que
multiplicar por menos 2 ahora para
llegar de 16 a menos 32 nuevamente hay
que multiplicar
- 2 entonces ya podemos intuir que que
el numerador va a ser una potencia de
menos 2 por ejemplo menos 8 menos 8 por
supuesto no es menos 2 al cuadrado
porque menos 2 al cuadrado sería 4
entonces menos 8 es menos 2 al cubo
muy bien 16 es menos 2 es menos 2 a la 4
estoy acá y menos 32 es menos dos a la
muy bien entonces en efecto el numerador
es una potencia de 2 y ahora fijémonos
cuál es la relación de la potencia con
el índice del término en la serie
entonces si nos damos cuenta el
exponente es uno mayor que el índice
verdad aquí es tres cuando el índice es
2 aquí es 4 cuando el índice straits y
así entonces lo que vamos a tener es que
nuestros términos a n a n van a ser
igual a en el numerador vamos a tener
menos 2 elevado al índice más 1 verdad
es el siguiente del índice vamos a ver
qué pasa ahora con el denominador por
ejemplo aquí tenemos 5
7 y 9 entonces estos denominadores son
los impares son los números impares y
este es el el el impar 5 luego 7 9 y
podemos intuir que sigue el 11 13 y
demás entonces como expresamos un impar
bueno este de aquí este de aquí es 2 por
2 más 1 verdad estoy acá será dos por
tres que son seis más uno y este de aquí
es dos por cuatro más uno entonces si
nos damos cuenta estos impares es
simplemente multiplicar por dos el
índice y luego sumarle uno entonces aquí
vamos a dividir entre dos por el índice
más uno así que finalmente la serie de
acá arriba se puede expresar de la
siguiente forma sumamos desde 2 hasta
infinito el menos 2
la n 1 sobre 2 n 1 y esta es la
respuesta